So let's see if we understand the
differences between message passing and
shared memory.
If we have a program in which one core
know how to initialize an array and
then all others need to read the entire
array, then the number of lines
of code for the data distribution of
the array once it has been initialized.
Does message passing have fewer lines
of code than shared memory for this?
Does it have about equal
number of lines of code?
Or do you think that it gets more
lines of code than shared memory,
in which case write a larger than sign?
And then once we have
achieved data distribution.
Synchronization that is needed to make
sure that the initialization is done
before we can read the array adds
how many lines of code in a message
passing version of the code, and in
the shared memory version of the code?
You only need to say whether it's 0 or
larger than 0.